[Music]
well u.s forces in afghanistan are in
the final phase of evacuations from the
capital just over 1 000 civilians are
waiting to be airlifted from kabul
airports more than 100 000 people have
been moved out since the taliban took
over two weeks ago the american troops
are the last western forces to withdraw
from afghanistan by the august 31st
deadline as u.s forces move out the
taliban is moving in the armed group is
aiming for swift handover of the airport
the final evacuations come under the
threat of another attack there u.s
president joe biden has warned of a
specific credible threat in the coming
hours but afghans are still trying to
make it to the facility
and pakistan that's already hosting
millions of afghan refugees they're now
preparing to receive more well let's
speak live now to charlotte bella she
joins us uh from cabral charlotte so we
understand that even though the clock is
counting down people are still trying to
make it to the airport to be airlifted
out of the country just bring us up to
speed with how things are going this
hour
evacuations are certainly slowing but
people are still trying this morning we
met with dozens of people just outside
our bureau who were trying to get on
buses in an effort to get into the
evidence on these evacuation flights but
they told us later that they were
unsuccessful there were students coming
from american university of afghanistan
now there are certainly fewer flights
landing taking off as of if you look at
the radar right now there are no us air
force flights at kabul airport and their
allies have gone too the british air
force their last flight took off last
night ending their evacuation mission
and also their military presence here
over the last 20 years
so as these foreign forces pull out the
taliban is pushing in we got exclusive
access inside the airport as these final
evacuations took place just meters from
taliban fighters
the taliban has taken over their
fighters drive us-made humvees laden
with us-made weapons around the last u.s
military installation in afghanistan
they look and act like former afghan
government soldiers the white flag the
only indication this is the taliban
it has been 20 years since the taliban
controlled kabul airport fighters
entered the capital two weeks ago and
quickly encircled it
the armed group had an agreement with
the u.s that it would remain outside and
secure the perimeter until evacuations
came to an end now with only two days to
go the u.s footprint is shrinking
when did you get hold of this area
in uh too hard two hours ago yeah yes we
come here zero one fourth afghanistan
so they've evacuated yes
clutching the us-made m4 rifles they've
commandeered taliban fighters watch as
american troops move inside the
perimeter destroy equipment and bus in
evacuees
behind that door is american soldiers
[Music]
and you are taliban
and they are in this watchtower also
that's our results of american soldiers
this is all
no they're over there too
[Music]
fighters count the number of c-17
aircraft departing from the end of the
runway
the taliban secured the commercial side
of the airport almost two weeks ago but
only pushed into military areas on
friday night their version of special
forces known as the badgery313 and
victoria strikeforce are in charge of
security
we are not here to protect the americans
we are here to prevent looting of this
place and the military equipment the
promises we made in doha we are standing
by them
these taliban officials are walking from
the neighboring ministry of interior a
compound they now control
as the us evacuates the taliban is
taking control of more areas inside the
airport they say they are very happy but
they wouldn't express that on camera
because they say i'm a woman and not
dressed appropriately
instead they discuss among themselves
how to secure the area and survey the
territory they now control
we have been in war for 20 years and we
believed one day we would get
afghanistan back these foreign forces
who came to afghanistan could not stop
us from getting our country back
patiently they wait for the last
american plane to take off
after three days and with the permission
of our commanders we will push fully
inside the airport
after 20 years thousands of people
killed and billions of dollars spent the
us is leaving afghanistan these are the
final hours of america's longest war
i will show that the taliban may now be
in control of parts of the airport but
there are still threats other knots on
that facility
yeah they're essentially having to deal
with this threat of isil because they're
in charge of securing the perimeter and
that is what is under threat president
biden saying last night 24 to 36 hours
that there was a high highly likely uh
threat of an attack by isil at the south
entrance which they're controlling and
also at that north western corner where
we filmed yesterday and i can tell you
last night that they were incredibly
worried it was very tense they were
trying to hold people back uh stop
crowds forming because they knew that
that elevated the threat of a repeat of
attack like we saw on thursday
okay charlotte bellas there live for us
from kabul thank you charlotte
pakistan's security adviser says the
number of afghans crossing into the
country is under control kamal heiser
has more from islamabad
well there have been reports that
there's a number of people that are
crossing the afghan border has increased
we've been in touch with the united
nations high commission for refugees who
say they don't see that at the moment
and one of the primary reasons for that
is that there was hardly any bloodshed
in afghanistan most of the people living
along the contiguous areas of pakistan
are ethnically pushed soon but it is
also noteworthy that thousands of
afghans come to pakistan for medical
assistance despite the fact that the
international community has invested
billions of dollars there are no proper
facilities medical facilities and that
forces thousands of afghans to come and
seek help here in pakistan
the warning of an imminent attack on
kabul airport comes after the pentagon
said it targeted members of isil's wing
in afghanistan in a drone strike on
friday the strike in nangarhar province
was in response to the kabul airport
attack gabriel elizondo reports from
washington d.c
friday's drone strike that killed two
isil k members and wounded another was
the first retaliatory strike against the
group but according to president joe
biden it won't be the last it's unclear
if those killed had a direct role in
thursday's airport attack that killed
over 150 afghans and over a dozen u.s
military personnel
the pentagon won't release the names of
the isil k members they killed only
saying they were planning future attacks
i am not going to talk about
specific capabilities isis may have lost
and in this strike they lost a planner
and they lost a facilitator and they've
got one wounded uh and the fact that two
of these individuals are no long longer
walking on the face of the earth that's
a good thing it's a good thing for the
people of afghanistan it's a good thing
for our troops and our forces at that
airfield and i think i'm just going to
leave it there
while the u.s and the taliban are
coordinating on airport security that
cooperation did not extend to the drone
strike
a taliban spokesperson told reuters news
agency they should have been informed
before the airstrike took place
in a statement saturday afternoon biden
said the chance of another terrorist
attack in the next 24 to 36 hours is
very high
it's believed around 4 000 u.s troops
are still at the airport in kabul and
commanders say despite the risks the
mission continues until the august 31st
deadline biden has put in place
threats to our forces and to this
operation remain real and significant
i'm sure you can appreciate that and now
as the military mission trend begins to
end in kabul thousands of service
members are working across the globe and
within the united states to complete
this incredibly important mission
caught in the middle innocent afghan
civilians at an airport near washington
on saturday afghan evacuees continued to
arrive in america after an arduous
journey
well i would say
last six or seven days
have been the toughest days of my life
honestly i don't want to lie or i don't
want to exaggerate but that is how it is
things are really bad
all around the airport all the entrances
and uh
you kind of feel lucky if you can get
just through those gates
over the weekend america was learning
more of the u.s service members killed
in the suicide attack
max soviet a navy medic was one of them
he was only two years old when the u.s
invaded afghanistan in 2001
friends and family back in his hometown
of ohio are grieving his death
he was just a really
good kid and
you know that everybody liked everybody
loves the family
just very
well respected
the u.s military pull-out from
afghanistan was measured in months and
then weeks and now it's down to days and
it could be the most unpredictable and
dangerous phase of all
with president biden simultaneously
warning americans that there could be
more attacks against u.s troops in kabul
while also more strikes against those
the u.s says is responsible
gabriel lozando al jazeera